[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
aujourd'hui mon objectif est de vous
faire toucher du doigt les limites de
l'univers ou du moins de vous montrer
comment la recherche en astrophysique
permet aujourd'hui d'étudier ses limites
je suis doctorat en astrophysique
laboratoire de physique de l'école
normale supérieure et mon travail
s'inscrit dans cette recherche aux
frontières de l'univers ma thèse est à
la croisée de plusieurs domaines dont je
vais tâcher de vous donner un aperçu la
cosmologie qui s'intéressent à la
formation et à l'évolution de notre
univers l'astrophysique qui s'intéresse
aux propriétés des objets qui peuplent
l'univers est la science des données qui
apporte aujourd'hui des méthodes
nouvelles pour comprendre nos
observations
mais commençons par préciser ce que l'on
entend par limites de l'univers notre
univers nous semblent infinies déjà
parce q quel que soit l'endroit où l'on
regarde quelle que soit l'échelle que
l'on sonde
on a l'impression de toujours trouver
quelque chose regardez simplement le
ciel par une nuit claire dans un endroit
retiré les étoiles semblent innombrables
présente partout autour de nous
maintenant quand on commence à regarder
méthodiquement le ciel en utilisant des
instruments d'observation télescope ou
autre on comprend qu'au plus proche de
nous il ya des planètes et une étoile le
soleil
cela forme le système solaire et des
systèmes solaires comme le nôtre il y en
a des centaines de milliards autour de
nous cela constitue notre galaxie la
voie lactée et les galaxies c'est pareil
on estime aujourd'hui que le nombre de
galaxies observable se comptent en
milliers de milliards et les galaxies ne
sont pas répartis de manière homogène
dans l'univers elles s'agglomèrent en
ama et forment des structures de
matières qui ressemble à une
gigantesque toile d'araignée la toile
cosmique
intéressons-nous maintenant aux
distances qui séparent ces objets en
astrophysique les distances s'exprime à
partir de la vitesse de la lumière
la vitesse de la lumière vaut
approximativement 300 mille kilomètres
par seconde
qu'est ce que cela veut dire cela veut
dire que si vous pouviez vous déplacer à
la vitesse de la lumière
vous feriez près de huit fois le tour de
la terre en une seconde pour nous
parvenir juste du soleil les photons ces
grains de lumière ont besoin de huit
minutes
maintenant si l'on regarde la distance
qui nous sépare de l'étoile la plus
proche
autre que le soleil elle se compte en
années lumière il faut plus de quatre
ans pour qu'un photon de cette étoile
proxima du centaure nous parviennent sur
terre allons encore plus loin pour qu'un
photon nous parviennent de l'autre bout
de la galaxie il faut attendre plus de
cent mille ans et même la lumière que
l'on observe aujourd'hui de la galaxie
d'andromède a été émise d'andromède
alors que la terre était encore peuplé
d'australopithèques c'est-à-dire il ya
2.5 millions d'années et la galaxie
d'andromède est plutôt considéré comme
proche de nous parmi les galaxies de
l'univers
donc je vous ai cité des populations
d'objets astrophysique innombrables des
distances écrasante mais il ya quand
même quelque chose de finir dans cet
univers c'est son âge nos modèles
cosmologiques arrive à dater l'univers
le début de sa formation remontrer à il
ya plus de 13,7 milliards d'années
voilà enfin quelque chose de fini bon
enfin c'est un peu plus compliqué que ça
disons que nos modèles physiques
arrivent à expliquer l'évolution de
l'univers jusqu'à il ya 13,7 milliards
d'années au delà nos théories ne
fonctionne plus et même ce que l'on
appelle le big bang le temps héros de
l'univers ne demeure qu'une curiosité
une singularité
bref une limite de nos théories
cette très brève description de
l'univers que je viens de vous faire et
que probablement certains d'entre vous
connaissent déjà n'a quand même rien
d'évident l'humanité a mis beaucoup de
temps pour comprendre tout ça il a fallu
attendre le début du xviie siècle pour
que les premiers instruments
d'observation du ciel apparaissent
lorsque galilée popularise la lunette
astronomique et c'est à partir du 19ème
siècle que l'on comprend pour la
première fois que les points lumineux
fixe que l'on observe la nuit sont du
même type que la boule de gaz chaud qui
illumine nos journées des étoiles etc
des dents dans les années 1920 qui edwin
hubble réalise que les objets lumineux
diffus qui l'observent la nuit et qu'il
a baptisée nébuleuse sont des objets
bien plus distant est bien plus riche
que les étoiles
ce sont des galaxies et même la
compréhension de l'univers à plus grande
échelle encore les la toile cosmique et
les premières observations corroborant
le modèle du big bang ne date que de la
seconde moitié du 20e siècle
toutes ces connaissances sont donc des
connaissances de pointe dans le monde
scientifique et elle évolue et se
précise en permanence revenons
maintenant sur cette question de la
finitude de l'univers aujourd'hui on ne
sait pas si l'univers est fini ou infini
on ne sait pas si l'univers un bord une
frontière
de quoi presque en être angoissé bon en
fait
l'eac encore quelque chose de finir dans
cette histoire c'est la partie de
l'univers qui nous est accessible on
parle d'univers observable bah oui
rien ne va plus vite que la lumière et
on n'a jamais rien observé de plus vieux
que le début de la formation de
l'univers il ya 13,7 milliards d'années
donc voici déjà quelque chose dans
l'opération reprenons l'univers
peut-être fini ou infini son domaine
observable lui reste fine et les
scientifiques arrivent aujourd'hui à
étudier des limites de cet univers
observable et de kelly limite observable
par le ton en as trop
physique puis on regarde loin plus on
regarde dans le passé
ceci car rien ne va plus vite que la
lumière ainsi les limites physiques de
l'univers se rapporte à son passé et le
travail du cosmologistes qui
s'intéressent à l'histoire de l'univers
se rapporte au travail de l'archéologue
qui s'intéressent à l'histoire de
l'humanité il travaille à partir de
vestiges du passé et pour étudier
l'histoire de l'univers il existe un
vestige prédilection qui s'appelle le
fond diffus cosmologique en nom un peu
barbare le fond diffus cosmologique est
un signal lumineux qui date du début de
l'univers à quelques centaines de
milliers d'années près et qui provient
des limites de l'univers observable
essayant de comprendre d'où vient ce
fond diffus cosmologique
intéressant non pour cela au modèle du
big bang dans le modèle du big bang il
ya 13,7 milliards d'années l'univers
l'univers entre alors très vite dans une
phase d'expansion brutale appelée
inflation et pendant cette phase
d'expansion univers et site chaux est si
dense que la lumière elle même et comme
séquestrés par la matière et il faut
attendre que la température et la
densité de l'univers diminue
suffisamment pour qu'un découplage entre
la matière et le rayonnement s'opère et
à partir de ce moment là environ 380
mille ans après le big bang
pour la première fois dans l'univers une
lumière parvient enfin à se propager
librement et ce qui est fabuleux c'est
que cette lumière tapant quasiment du
début de l'univers est encore
observables partout autour de nous
aujourd'hui cette lumière est en quelque
sorte la première lumière de l'univers
waouh bon et maintenant concrètement
comment observer
moncef lumière cette lumière était
observée pour la première fois en 1965
par deux physiciens arnaud penzias et
robert wilson
ils sont tombés dessus un peu par hasard
il travaillait sur un nouveau type
d'antenne radio pour les laboratoires a
bel et bien sûr depuis des instruments
bien plus sophistiqués ont pu observer
cette lumière ce fond diffus
cosmologique notamment le satellite
planck qui est envoyé dans l'espace en
2009 et toutes ces observations ont
permis de dresser la carte sur le ciel
du fond diffus cosmologique à voici
cette carte du fond diffus cosmologique
montre les variations de température
autour d'une température centrale de
2,725 degrés kelvin je vous ai parlé de
lumière et d'un coup je vous montre une
carte du ciel en température je vous
rassure il s'agit juste d'une autre
façon de mesurer la lumière il se trouve
que le fond diffus cosmologique
correspond au signal lumineux qui
émettrait un corps idéal porté à la
température de 2,725 degrés kelvin en
cosmologie cette carte fluctuations de
température s'interprète comme
correspondant aux germes des grandes
structures de l'univers étudier les
propriétés du fond diffus cosmologique
permettrait alors de mieux comprendre le
modèle qui explique la formation et
l'évolution de l'univers s'appelle le
modèle standard de la cosmologie le
modèle standard de la cosmologie
explique l'apparition des grandes
structures de l'univers à partir de la
compétition entre force de gravité et
expansion de l'univers par le biais de
ces phénomènes physiques des
inhomogénéités initiale de matières ont
fait émerger cette grande toile
d'araignée la toile cosmique et c'est
indirectement dans cette carte de
fluctuation de température que l'on
observe c'est i know me
l'aîné ite initiale de matière et donc
comment les scientifiques concrètement
étudie ce signal en fait l'étude de ce
signal se fait de manière principalement
statistiques cela principalement parce
que les inhomogénéités initiale de
matières sont intrinsèquement aléatoire
alors qu'est ce que cela veut dire
cela veut dire que cette carte de
fluctuation de température a été comme
tirés au sort parmi de nombreuses autres
cartes au potentiel même l'univers dans
lequel nous vivons correspond en quelque
sorte à un lancer de dés je m'explique
si vous prenez un des standards à six
faces que vous lancez vous pouvez tomber
sur un deux trois quatre cinq ou six et
vous avez autant de chance de tomber sur
un 1 sur 1 2 / 3 / 4 / 5 / 1 6 on parle
de loi uniforme dans une certaine mesure
l'univers dans lequel nous vivons
correspond à un lancer de dés il en
donnait 1 1 mais aurait pu tout aussi
être un 2e en 3 ou autre il y à une
nuance quand même c'est que la loi qui
régit la statistique de ce fond diffus
cosmologique n'est pas la même que celle
d'un lancer de dés
ce n'est pas une loi uniforme mais une
loi dite gaussienne on dit que le fond
diffus cosmologique est un chant gosses
ya alors en théorie des probabilités la
loi gaussienne apparaît assez
naturellement dès que l'on s'intéresse à
des événements indépendants qui suivent
la même loi de probabilité
pour revenir à notre analogie des
lancers de dés imaginez que l'on ans dix
mille fois le même dès qu'on le regarde
la valeur moyenne de s'élancer
lorsque l'on répète cette expérience on
observe que cette valeur moyenne suis
loi qui ressemble de plus en plus à une
loi gaussienne et ceci n'est pas un
hasard
ceci correspond à un théorème de la
théorie des probabilités s'appelle le
théorème centrale limite pour le fond
diffus cosmologique
on observe exactement le même type de
lois en tout point du ciel une loi
gossip
si l'on regarde la distribution des
fluctuations de température du fond
diffus cosmologique
on voit apparaître cette même courbe en
cloche cette loi gaussienne bon nos
observations montrent que le fond diffus
cosmologique est en adéquation avec
cette loi gaussienne mais en fait pas
tout à fait en fait certaines mesures
statistiques montrent des écarts à cette
loi gaussienne on parle de nombreux
ciani t qu'est ce que cela veut dire
on peut imaginer plusieurs explications
à ces écarts alors soit le fond diffus
cosmologique n'est pas en fait aux siens
et ce qui a précédé son émission
notamment cette phase appelée
l'inflation a peut-être fait émerger et
négociabilité ou peut-être que le fond
diffus cosmologique ego siens mais que
ce que l'on observe aujourd'hui est un
signal qui était complètement déformés
bah oui ce signal est quand même très
vieux il ya 13,7 milliards d'années
est ce que l'on observe aujourd'hui et
peut-être qu'un signal parasité par ce
que l'on peut appeler des avants plan
donc que c'est avant plan introduit ses
nombreuses qualités pour nos
observations très bien supposons que le
fond diffus cosmologique ergo sien et
que des avants plan ont parasité ce fond
diffus cosmologique quel type de
phénomène peut pas résister fond diffus
cosmologique peut citer la déviation de
la lumière par la matière c'est un effet
de relativité générale les lentilles âge
gravitationnelle où on peut citer un
autre phénomène qui est le fait qu on
observe une superposition de deux
signaux le fond diffus cosmologique plus
un signal galactique
oui notre galaxie la voie lactée et mais
une lumière très intense à la
statistique complexe et qui se superpose
deux observations du fond diffus
cosmologique
et même lorsqu'on essaie de la retirer
finement de nos observations des résidus
non gaussien demeure dans nos cartes du
fond diffus cosmologique et aujourd'hui
nos exigences de précision dans nos
mesures
et son tel qu'il apparaît capitale de
mieux comprendre ces écarts la loi
gauciel ses nombreux ciani tu es dans
nos observations en fait autant la loi
gaussienne est très simple à décrire il
suffit de deux nombres les valeurs
moyennes et un écart-type autant une loi
non gaussienne peut vite devenir très
compliqué à décrire est bon quand mon
travail de tel j'utilise des outils
issus de la science des données pour
mieux comprendre ces noms gosses yani t
vous savez cette science qui est
nouvelle et qui apporte plein de
techniques nouvelles pour mieux traiter
nos données de manière statistique donc
pour vous nous expliquer en demande à
quoi ressemble mon travail on dira que
l'on décrit suffisamment bien et non
dossier and it et que l'on observe en
ses avants plan du fond diffus
cosmologique
si à partir d'un certain nombre de
mesures statistiques on est capable de
reproduire des signaux similaires pour
vous donner un exemple voici une
simulation image extraite d'une
simulation dans l'avant plan galactique
cette sorte de lumière qui parasitent
toutes nos observations du fond diffus
cosmologique et on dirait que l'on a
réussi à capturer la statistique de
cette image si à partir de mesures on
est capable de reproduire des images
visuellement similaires et on voit bien
que le choix de notre mesure le choix de
notre outil statistique est déterminant
pour capturer la statistique de notre
image de départ le défi est donc
aujourd'hui de trouver le meilleur outil
statistique pour capturer ces noms de
socialité dans nos avants plan du fond
diffus cosmologique voilà
maintenant vous savez comment l'on peut
étudier cet univers si vous semble
infini à notre échelle jusque dans ses
extrêmes limites observable par le fond
diffus cosmologique les statistiques
jouent un rôle de premier plan lors
l'étude de ce signal et c'est
aujourd'hui avec des outils novateurs
que l'on parviendra à capter les détails
les plus fins de ce signal nous
permettant alors de préciser les
histoires de notre univers je vous
remercie
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]